Rey has been using hand-me-downs since the
first moment she touched a lightsaber in The
Force Awakens, but with the ending of The
Rise of Skywalker, she finally has one of
her own.
Here's what Rey's new lightsaber really means.
In The Force Awakens, Rey first wielded Luke
Skywalker's old lightsaber, which originally
belonged to Anakin Skywalker.
With Emperor Palpatine finally defeated, Rey
returns to where fans' journey with Star Wars
began 42 years ago: the Lars family moisture
farm on the planet Tattooine, where Luke grew
up.
Rey buries both Luke's famous lightsaber and
the one Leia used when she was training to
become a Jedi in the desert near the farm,
before pulling out a new lightsaber she has
finally forged for herself.
Fortunately for fans, it's not the double-bladed
red lightsaber seen in the trailers for The
Rise of Skywalker.
The lightsaber that Rey ends up with is a
yellow lightsaber, which is quite rare in
the Star Wars universe.
The yellow lightsaber has most often been
seen in the galaxy far, far away in the hands
of the Temple Guards on the animated series
Star Wars: The Clone Wars.
Of course, Rey is certainly not joining the
Temple Guard, considering the Jedi temple
would be fairly empty given the lack of Jedi.
But there's plenty of other symbolism attached
to the yellow lightsaber as well.
Star Wars lore dictates that yellow lightsabers
are carried by the Sentinels, one of the major
schools of thought within the old Jedi Order
that tries to find balance between the Consulars,
which typically bear green blades, and the
Guardians, who normally wield blue lightsabers.
With the Sith apparently destroyed by the
end of The Rise of Skywalker, Rey has finally
brought balance to the Force.
Not only that, but she also appears to be
the only Jedi left, and will have to carry
the beliefs of them all into the future.
There's also the symbolic decision for Rey
to deviate from what has come before her.
Rey has had quite the journey: she was a poor
scavenger girl abandoned on Jakku by her parents
who spent most of her life waiting for them
to come back to her, then discovered that
she's Force-sensitive, began training as a
Jedi under Luke Skywalker, joined the Resistance
and fought against the First Order, found
out she's a Palpatine, and ultimately decided
to take the surname Skywalker as her own.
She had plenty of options from which to choose
in claiming her own lightsaber, she could
have been blue or green like Luke and Leia,
or red like her cackling electric grandpa.
But in choosing to go a different way with
her lightsaber, Rey chooses her own identity
separate from her bloodline and her past.
Given the way that Rey grew up, that is, scavenging
as the only way to survive in a desert wasteland,
she knows firsthand how important knowledge
outside the Force can be to survival.
That's just what the Sentinels believed.
All things considered, it makes perfect sense
that she would choose to follow the school
of thought embodied by the Sentinels in forging
her own lightsaber.
Additionally, it was important for Rey to
put Luke and Leia's lightsabers to rest and
forge one of her own.
It's a critical part of the process to becoming
a Jedi Master, and until she did so, would
have rendered her journey incomplete.
Star Wars lore also dictates that the kyber
crystals used to create the light in a lightsaber
are white, and only take on a color once they
have bonded with a Jedi and their path becomes
clear.
The message here is an obvious one: Rey, the
last of the Jedi Order, will embody all that
the Jedi are.
From the Consulars to the Guardians to learning
real-life skills, Rey carries the entire future
of the Jedi Order within her, and she must
balance those teachings.
There's another small detail to Rey's new
lightsaber many may have missed.
The handle of her saber is made from the staff
she has been carrying around for years, since
long before she ever left Jakku in the first
place.
It's yet another piece of symbolism, showing
Rey finally leaving her old life behind her,
this time for good.
Even in The Rise of Skywalker, we saw that
Rey's education as a Jedi hadn't given her
the confidence to rely on her strength in
the Force just yet.
On the training ground, she was unable to
fight off the combat remote with the lightsaber,
but she disposed of it quickly using a stick
like her staff.
She has always been comfortable with the weapon
in her hand, so it makes perfect sense for
her to bring that relic forward with her into
her new life, without hanging on to any sentimentality
of her past.
It's understood that new Star Wars films won't
be telling the tale of the Skywalkers, of
which Rey is now one by choice thanks to her
final words in The Rise of Skywalker.
Considering The Rise of Skywalker marked the
end of the Skywalker saga, it's not likely
Rey will be returning in any more movies.
This ties in with one of the reasons the Sentinels
don't appear in the nine films already in
existence: those who practiced the beliefs
of the Sentinels believed in concealing themselves
and being inconspicuous, and avoided pulling
out their lightsabers unless absolutely necessary.
With the galaxy seemingly safe at the end
of The Rise of Skywalker, Rey shouldn't need
to whip out her new weapon that often, and
may even be able to fade into the background
just like the Sentinels.
But who knows?
Maybe she'll teach a whole new order of Jedi
in the future, and we'll meet her students
in a future Star Wars movie.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Star Wars films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.